depuis les attentats à saint jean sur
richelieu et au parlement d'ottawa
l'association qui représente les cent
mille musulmans de colombie britannique
veut plus que jamais prévenir ces cas de
radicalisation qui distille ternissent
l'image de leur religion dans les
prochaines semaines il plié même en
dehors des mosquées les ateliers et les
programmes de mentorat pour tenter de
remettre dans le droit chemin ce qui
nourrirait de funeste projet une formule
intéressante selon cet expert des
programme de déradicalisation 80% des
codes loup solitaire en fait peu à être
déjouée à cause de petits à cosa
communauté donc là la famille les pères
donc les amis et donc
donc c'est une piste intéressante en
fait afin de prévenir les actes et
verglas ce n'est pas toujours facile de
détecter ces cas d'autant plus que ce
type de programmes de sensibilisation
est souvent mise en place par des
bénévoles sans vraiment de budget ou de
ressources
la majorité des mosquées n'ont pas même
le budget pour payer a ni même d'une
façon décente
l'association des services sociaux
islamique du canada qui a déjà publié ce
livret d'information pour prévenir la
radicalisation reconnaît qu'il y encore
beaucoup à faire nous avons besoin
dit-elle de l'aide du gouvernement
fédéral et des services policiers aussi
qui bien souvent surveillés déjà
certains individus qui ont commis des
actes répréhensibles
la police canadienne selon ghislain
bélanger accuse d'ailleurs un retard sur
d'autres pays
sur le front de la radicalisation est
présentement la grc pas encore développé
un modèle compris en scène justement
pour pouvoir d'électriser les gens qui
sont dans la société
d'ici la fin du mois le gouvernement
fédéral devrait annoncer de nouvelles
mesures antiterroristes qui surtout
renforceront les pouvoirs des services
de renseignement canadiens les musulmans
d'ici qui eux voudraient participer aux
efforts attendent toujours les retours
d'appels d'ottawa ici frédéric arnould
radio canada vancouver